hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
personal youtube channel
where today i am announcing that i am
leaving rooster teeth
which for any of you who didn't know is
the company i've been working for for
the past
two and a half years it's two and a half
if you include all the visa paperwork
which i do because by god that's a job
this means that i will no longer be
working for funhouse and no longer
working for inside gaming
um you know being that i don't work for
rooster teeth anymore there are
like a bunch of things that i feel like
i should say um
about this particular announcement but
the main one just to get it right off
the gate is that i am
leaving because uh there's an
opportunity before me that i just
couldn't say no to that i just couldn't
not go for
i can't talk about that yet but when i
can
i feel like a lot of you will be very
understanding i think a lot of people
will um
very much understand why i've made this
decision especially when
to be completely honest both funhouse
and inside gaming are such
fun brands to work on and my job at
rooster teeth has been
so much fun that leaving even to me
feels insane
i just had to do it i had to um jump at
what's next for me
and yeah i'll tell you guys what that is
when i can for now
i wanted to first say
um to the funhouse audience just thank
you guys so much
i know that having a new person on um
at any company for any group dynamic uh
is always very weird at first but i felt
like
i got a ton of love and support from day
one and um
that is a credit to the funhouse
community and i mean this very seriously
i think i've said this before but in the
most sincere way possible
the funhouse community is absolutely
incredible i've worked for a lot of
online brands you know
a lot of of uh video game companies
across the board who've
had talent move in and out and fun house
is probably the only one that i've ever
worked for
where the audience just cares so much
where people are really like hey guys we
don't want you to overwork
take all the time that you need or we
hope you're all doing okay or if anyone
you know is so much as sick they like
they just care rather than
demanding more content which is
especially been a thing over the last
few weeks when
um of course you know we didn't upload
videos every day for a while because of
a thing that occurred which i guess i'll
just speak to here probably the only
time that i'll ever speak to it i have
tried not to speak about this kind of
situation the reason for that is that a
lot of my audience
has no idea who funhouse is and knows me
separately and thus if i talk about this
thing i bring a bunch of attention to it
for people who otherwise had no idea
what it is so i tried to protect
funhouse from that ultimately
but i feel like it's relevant in this
particular conversation so for anyone
who doesn't know basically
funhouse recently potted ways with an
employee and i bring this up because a i
wanted to say the community's been
incredible about
the reaction to that it was very
difficult on the team they took time off
and in the briefest way possible um
just to credit the audience i suppose to
to to say something
the team at funhouse knows more about
the situation than the public does
they learned more information as one
thing came out more things came up
privately that the public will likely
never know
for the privacy of those involved but
also for legal reasons but ultimately
yes there is more that the team
has learned about the situation then the
public
currently is aware of i'm being vague
intentionally to try to be respectful
frankly but there are subreddits about
this if you want to learn about it
but anyway my second point is i just
want to be very clear that i'm 100 not
leaving funhouse because of what
transpired there
the thing that i am going to do was
something that
was being discussed before that
situation went down
but also i truly believe that the team
at funhouse is stronger now than they've
been in a year and more positive right
now than they've been in
a while i think very unified um it's
the timing sucks it really sucks that i
have to leave right now i just can't not
no i hate it this isn't a alana is
leaving because of what happened
it is more of a alana wishes she wasn't
leaving
at this current period of time because
it absolutely sucks that this went down
that way
and that um the timing is what it is
i just don't want people to relate the
two because that's absolutely not the
case i have a lot of faith
in the funhouse team right now and think
they're in a really good spot
and um you know the content we've made
over the last few weeks has just been so
much fun
in a way that it maybe wasn't even
before there's like kind of a new energy
so i just
i really want to impart that that uh
this didn't happen because of that this
is all going to be very confusing to
anyone who's not heard of that situation
but i figure
people haven't heard of it probably
don't know who funhouse is anyway
so yes a huge thank you to the community
even stepping away from that
like i know that i'm like a pretty low
energy person on camera
who's just very passionate about video
games
and while i have in my career at two
other places that i worked literally
been the lead producer of comedy
gameplay series
you know that is part of my professional
background that is
why i started working at funhouse i was
doing that at ign for two separate
brands there so it's like
you know a thing that i do and i like to
have a laugh but i also just recognize
that you know i'm i am a low energy
person and i always have a giant coffee
every time you see me on screen
and i always feel like i just want to
thank people for tolerating that
i don't know i just whenever i compare
myself to like other
youtube brands everyone's like so high
energy and like oh my god hey guys
what's up
and like i don't have it in me but
nobody's ever forced me to be that
person
and i'm very grateful for it um because
i don't
i'm not that you know i'm not archetype
entertaining youtuber so thank you for
for you know being on board with that i
think that's probably largely because
the fun house audience is a bit older
than your usual gaming channel but still
i feel like i was always just supported
even when i was going through
pretty major health issues didn't upload
on this channel for like three months
community was always very kind and that
was something that i was nervous to
share
and i have no intention of you know
stopping being friends with any of the
people who work at funhouse
um i absolutely hope that i can
continue to to guest on content
obviously i'm going to fully commit to
the new thing that i'm working on that
would be
the absolute priority no question there
but this this might seem like a weird
announcement from from the fun house
side or even you know from
my side because for whatever reason it
doesn't really feel like i'm leaving the
family
secondly i guess to the team at funhouse
some just genuinely incredible
creative minds who work
for that brand who never get
enough credit for it but publicly those
editors are brilliant
honestly a lot of love and care between
those people and they were a pleasure to
work with and
there are some of them that i'd like
take with me to the grave that i wish i
could work with forever honestly
a lot of very brilliant people it was an
absolute pleasure working with you
even during one of the weirdest periods
of time of my life
for sure and of a lot of our lives
because you know comfort is covered
that's the situation it's been a weird
adjustment period this whole year
for us as it has for a lot of other
people but everyone just took it in
stride and nailed it and
um there is not a weak clink on that
team just
everyone is amazing honestly and thank
you for entertaining
some of my stupid ideas that i had a
really good time making
um that everyone was just like
absolutely let's do your stupid idea
alana
and then seeing how they all come
together with all these different people
and then the way the editors make their
magic and just watching these final
videos come out is always
just so awesome so much creativity on
display so thank you lastly i guess
um i didn't plan this video at all like
i know when i left ign i like had notes
for myself this one
i'm just i don't know what i'm talking
about yeah i can't tell you guys what
i'm going to do
just yet but um of course you will still
see me here on this youtube channel i do
make content with people who work at fun
house been doing a lot of stuff lately
with
rahul and john and jacob and i hope to
continue doing that because it's
a very fun group but i will certainly
even in my new position be a person who
makes things so that is not going
anywhere
and i'm very excited to be able to share
with you all what it is and i hope that
um
a lot of you will follow me on this
journey
and if not that is also cool thank you
for watching
i don't know what else to say um i guess
that's it
i'm alana and i will see you guys next
time bye